Hi, welcome. Nice to see a lot of familiar faces here.
I decided to start right on time now. Usually I start a little bit late because I don't know what time it is.
I just checked out four times. The reason is on Saturday.
I was thinking, hey, I've got to give a talk next Wednesday and I'm not sure I know enough stuff to say that'll make the lecture interesting.
So I started working on it on this topic of lettuces, of trees.
And now I've got I know I got the opposite worry. I think I've had too much to to do.
So I'll just tell you what, you know, as much as I as I will fit into our comfortably.
And if there's anything left over, well, there's always another Christmas coming up later.
This is a this is the fifth year in a row that I've given a lecture just before the end of the court of our winter quarter about trees.
So we call it the Christmas tree lecture. And in some ways, trees are about the most interesting thing in computer science, at least,
let's say computer scientists love trees more than anybody else and even poets love food.
So. So I don't know how many years I'll be able to go on with something really interesting new about trees, but I don't see any end in sight yet.
And today, I want to talk about lettuces, the trees.
I'm actually going to sit down and talk about it because I find out that they've got a lead camera up there in this in the ceiling.
And I can use that to show you a bunch of a bunch of stuff that as we're going.
So let's see.
You can see me there. Maybe maybe they can also project on the screen behind me.
I need. Yeah.
OK. So which is the monitor that actually corresponds.
This is the one. This is the one that you're seeing.
OK. So so let's first of all, how many people know what the lattices.
One person to see. OK. Yeah.
Except that there's at least two meanings of the lattices, just completely different meanings of a lot, you know, in mathematics even.
And and one in one class of people who who I think about lattices, they think of it as as integer points or something geometrical.
And those people are probably attending another lecture right now because they're competing with Jangala at the moment.
But then anyway, in in your letter, who's a really interesting and.
And that's another topic. But lattices that are that we're talking about today are the kind that logicians like better.
And these are the ones that are are about ah, the.
That they occur in mathematics when they're talking about the algebraic system called lattice.
And. And here's the idea. It's mainly based on the idea of ordering between between objects, in this case, between trees.
So we're going to have a partial ordering. Is that any transitive relation?
So we can say that that something is.
It is precedes something else. Let's say that the partial ordering top and written like this and maybe precedes the equals.
And it just means that if X precedes Y and Y, if we see Z, then then X also precedes Z.
Now, but then it's also has the greatest lower bounds between any two objects.
So. So and these are called the meat of the objects.
And so and it's often written X with a little wedge Y.
And this means that this is the sum. This is the largest thing.
That is the the largest thing that precedes X and precedes Y both.
And if there is such a greatest law bound, it means that anything that precedes X and Y has to precede X, meet Y.
And it also has the least upper bound on the on the opposite side, which is called the join X with a symbol Y.
And this is the same idea.
Anything that's greater than both X and Y is with respect to the partial wording has to be greater than the least upper bound but equal to not.
So this is the idea of the Arveladze and the harsh orderings all over the place when we want
to compare one object to another and say that that one is somehow dominates the other.
And many times this partial ordering also is the latest means that it has grayest or vandalize stuff about algebraically.
It's the equivalent to saying that we have these two operations meet conjoin and the they satisfy
the item important law X X equals X and also X join X is X and then it has its commutative law.
So, you know, X, Y equals X and this is the same idea.
Changing all means the joint associative. And also one more thing is absorptive.
And this is the thing that so both meet and join our community of associative item Potente also its objective,
which means that if you take the meat of X with X, join with Y,
you get X and similarly take the joint of X with the meat of X and Y, you get Access's.
So now algebraically, if you take any system that satisfies these axioms, you also can define a partial ordering.
And this turns out to be the growth for vandalize. Well, this is all abstract, so I want to get into concrete stuff.
And today I'm talking about that this is in threes. So we want to find pressure ordering on threes so that we can say that if you have two threes,
there's a there's a meat of these two trees and there's a joint of these two trees,
which means it's the it's the largest thing that is less than both threes are the smallest thing that's created in both threes,
according to this ordering that we have.
And so we're going to nearly take two trees and say that that that one is somehow bigger than another, not or something.
Now, actually, I'm going to but the two trees are going to have the same number of of nodes.
Same number of vertices in the tree.
And so what I want to talk about is actually three different ways to define the concept of order on trees with the same size.
We'll be able to say that one tree is somehow, you know, shapely, then another, whatever, some some some idea of the of the ordering on the trees.
And actually, I'm not going to. And actually, I'm going to talk about forest and trees.
Trees, not now. Forest is is a bunch of trees.
And in fact, we're talking we're talking ordered forest. So. So I'm saying. So.
So I said a forest. Oh actually I, I got a random forest which I.
Which I. Which I found by my computer on Saturday.
Just wanted a random example. So I use pi and I figured out how to find a particular forest with 10 nodes.
And so here I come. I mean a number of the nodes in the forest.
A b. I don't name them. ABC. D e f g h.
I j. Because there are ten nodes.
And I also am arranging them so that the that the names of these, of these nodes come out in what we call pre order of the forest.
Pre order is the same order as, like the the order of succession to the throne.
So if these were the people here. It's part of British royalty or something like this.
This would be the the the the queen or the whoever occupies the throne now.
And this would be the. But if this person dies in, this one would would be next.
And if that person dies, this will be next. Then their firstborn. And then that person's child.
And then they're their first born second for anybody. If all of these are are dead.
Then h you know, then this guy comes in and then we go actually to another other line.
If you ever saw Alec Guinness movie where he actually systematically kills all the people that were ahead of him.
You understand this. You understand this.
This principle now. OK. So this is a this is a forest.
And it means it has it's a it's a ordered set of trees.
And the and in each family, the children are also ordered to the first one second one.
Now, a tree would be a case where there's only one one.
You can only think of a forest as a as if it were a tree.
Because you can imagine that there's some parent out, out, out of the top who has a and I as their as.
As a two children. And so a plus one node is is a tree.
And conversely a tree minus its root node is the forest.
So. It's worked. I'm going to work on force. Turns out to be a little bit nicer because, you know, is always there is a white so.
So, you know, I don't have to drive. Like, if if it if I consider force and the trees.
Now, the first I'm going to do is I'm going to talk about three different lattices on trees.
And one of the lattices is invented by a Frenchman named and I can't pronounce it correctly for any French.
Here you can tell me. But I'm going to say crueler. Charmain Kurath is nineteen seventy two.
Then there is another one which was invented by those Kamari in his Ph.D. thesis in Cork in 1954.
And then there's the third lattice on Forest, which was by Richard Stanley.
And this was published in 1975. So these are going to be clear that these are kind of natural ways to define art.
We'll see.
You find ordering on trees that also turn out to give us the latest now of the fact that there's so many different ways to get a lattice off of trees.
This is a little bit confusing because somebody because tomorrow let us was sort of got famous as being a lattice about trees.
And so when people came up with we're studying trees and they found some ordering that had the lightest properties,
they thought they must have the Temari letters.
But, you know, I know several cases where people have the standing lattice and they thought they were dealing with the tomalis and so on.
Not now. Kurath didn't actually talk specifically about about forests or trees.
He had a different way of thinking about it. But it's isomorphic. It's it.
He really would talk about forest if he had, you know, if he'd been a computer scientist.
But this is what he was talking about is is that is equivalent to the forest.
I'll show your courses or the first. And it's this.
So, so, so, so the first of all, we have the Kurath lattice.
And this says and we have to define a partial ordering between to be between two forest.
So so we say that F is kuris less than or equal to G.
This is my symbol here for Crookes. Less than or equal.
This will mean that if. If X and Y siblings, members of the same family in G, then then they also in X and then they're also siblings in F.
They are also siblings. And so it's in other words, it's all based on who.
Who are the. Who are the members of the same family? Are they the same generation?
So in this case, for example, the sibling be has no siblings.
She has no siblings. This only child denature siblings. Yes.
Is only child FFG are siblings. He and I are considered siblings because the roots of the two of the of the of the two trees.
And we imagine that there's some parent out there who has a and so he and I are considered siblings.
So if we look in the if we look at the nodes, we don't really have to have labels on these nodes by this ABC.
I'm just doing this for convenience so I can talk about a node that actually has always the node that's first and preorder V is always the No.
The second issue, C is always the third and so on. So if the.
So what it says. That's it. Anything that if the third.
If the third. And if nodes in preorder are siblings in G then the third.
Then in F also the third and eighth node should be siblings. And I can show you the the way Chris himself drew this lattice.
It's conventional. It's conventional to have a lattice diagram where we put the smallest element at the bottom, the largest element up at the top.
And he was missing here. Only the only the families, the siblings, A, B, C, D.
Here, here he has A, B, C, D, that means B and C, I siblings A&E are not connected to them and so on.
And and so if you count up those 14 different ways to, you know, 14 different points in his diagram here and there, there are.
Because out there, if the sibling it is in such that relation, actually,
actually this relation turns out that the that that this is that by the ordering that that he defined it, he actually reversed John F here.
I'm I'm going to actually do it upside down and end up the reason to be clear in a minute.
But this is Chris from Chris's actual paper, 1972.
But so here you're being D are together. So. So this will be connected to the one up above will be Indio's still together.
And so that's it. That's the idea. It's very simple idea.
And there are 14 different forest possible on four points now.
However, I don't know. I'm a little unhappy about his diagram because it doesn't show the symmetry of the situation.
It actually, I. I'm studying, too.
Yeah. You know, when when I write books, I'm, I, I give a diagram, I think in this and there's some way to rearrange the points of the diagram.
So that's so that there will be a more a more symmetrical pattern.
I think that's more informative. And there's you know,
there's a there's six factorial ways to rearrange these guys given these and some of those are going to look more symmetrical than the others.
And you can see patterns better. So I read Grant.
Here is another. This is another paper on the on the curious lattice that came out just three years ago.
And again, they do it a little different, but it's still they didn't.
They didn't show symmetry. So I'm going to I'm going to just try the lattice symmetrical way.
Here's my my favorite way to draw that Kurath lattice.
Four. Four. Four, four. And four points. And. And it's symmetrical.
Minus symmetrical. We were in a hut in the sense that if you turn it this way, you'd get the same.
The red lines are the same lines between so.
So there is this this kind of a flip operation that that says that the latest from the bottom up is the same.
It looks the same as the top down.
So it was okay for me to the changes, but the main reason I lose, I changed the order so that what he called the bottom was was for me the top,
because it gets conventional to call a top element of a lattice one. And this force just looks a lot more like one.
And then the other one I hated hated to see that one sitting at the bottom.
So, so. So I flipped it over now. But, you know, if.
So I could have, if you like, a definition that has F first instead of G.
I said if X and Y are not siblings in F then they're not siblings in G.
And that's it. That's equivalent definition is the contrapositive thing. That's the No.
So here we have it. Here you can see it for us. For example, up at the top of this one.
So if. If you know, you know if.
Let's see, what am I saying? I do find it. If there are siblings in the hiwa, in the big one, then they're still leaving the smaller.
So certainly this guy is is bigger than everything else because this doesn't have any children at all.
So it's no condition. And this one is smart because everybody is together there.
So here here we have a case where ANC, our siblings being are not good because in this particular case, these are Salvaje and the ANC are siblings.
So the ones that come underneath that ANC are still siblings.
This guy and this guy, A, B and C, the only the only place.
OK. So that's the that's the chorus, ladies.
And we can then also, you know, say that this is equivalent to saying, gee, is is a reverse chorus of F actually I would you know,
I would make this K and a in a light font so that it would look like a symbol instead of a letter.
And then you can say that then it according to this latest, the.
Let's let this be the the meat of F and G. And this would be the the greatest all about.
And this would be the joint will be written this way.
So it's just an ordinary meat joint symbol.
But with this extra line on there to remember that, we've got to distinguish crews from Samarian and Stanly in this.
In this, we're gonna have many lattices going the same on the same time on the same forest.
OK. So that's the definition. Now let's try to to analyze something about it.
So so that's the main thing that we that we want to do in a finite lattice.
The important thing is what they call covering. And this means that that one one forest covers another.
It means that it's less than the other. But there's nothing in between.
So so. So, I mean, the transit of the.
So if so if if F is less than G is less than H, then F is less than eight.
But then H doesn't cover F the things that cover F are the things that are just bigger than F.
But not any. There's nobody in between. And in a finite lattice,
we can you can find the one thing that that's directly precede in the red lines in this diagram are the ones that that cover that natural.
So what covers what. So, so. So this would go to here and then that would go.
Yes. So this is less than this. And what is covering looked like in the crew in the Kuis lattice.
Well, let's suppose we have some kind of a force and an up and some part of a tree within the forest.
So so here's a for example, might have somebody has five descendants and whatever their names are, and then they have some tree below them.
And then there might also be this guy might also have have siblings on either side and might be a descendant of of other things.
But somehow we're looking at a part of them, of a big forest. So there's some environment to this to this situation.
And then I'm going to amputate this.
This diagram. And I'm going to move and say, let's say part of it, let's say and say these two.
I can take one or two or any number, except I can't remove the left left trial of the family.
And I and I fastened those two below the one that was just to their left.
This is a an example of covering. I'm not sure if it caused me to join.
I kept flipping this diagram up of upside down, back and forth.
But let's let's put an arrow here. So imagine that I could imagine this operation.
You have some some huge forest. Are you going to talk to one of the families of the forest while you pick up some adjacent people?
Not not if not at the left end. And you pull them down and attach them to to the to the to the at the very end of the sibling to the right.
Now, at the very end, what I mean is that whoever is last in the tree order in, in your in the brother here, this guy or the the sibling is this guy.
Then if we look at the efforts at one order there's gonna be somebody who who is last.
And then and then we then the preorder will flip over this tree.
And so that person will be somebody chalice.
And so we can give him a family now. So so we can take these and moving down to and put them up.
We can attach him to this other to this other place.
And by the way, a note in effect in a forest that's that has no.
It's called a leaf. And so what we've done here is actually we've reduced the number of leaves by
one because all the leaves that were that were in these trees are still there,
except for the for the leap, for the right most guy in this branch.
So by moving this down, I, I decrease the number leaves.
But I but I preserve the pre order,
I preserve the order of succession to the throne because everybody here still is going to come in the same order that they had before.
And and what, what, what, what changes have I made to families.
Well, here, here we had these five people were siblings and here three of them are still siblings and these other two are still siblings.
So it turns out that everybody who is siblings down here is still siblings up here.
So this must be actually the thing at higher up in the tree.
And we look if we look at that lattice now, we should see then if we if we rank things,
we start out with with one leaf, two leaves, three leaves, four leaves.
So, so, so the level that you're at in the Crusades is the number of leaves in the forest.
And so if you're if you're if if you're to keep to forest, they have the same number of leaves.
There's no way that you could that one is going to be ordered.
And the other one according to the clearest method. That's OK.
OK. That's an idea. Now. Next thing I want to tell you about is duality, kindness.
This is the idea of flipping over the diagram so that look is going to look the same the other way.
So that says that every forest is going to correspond to another forest. That's the duel of that forest.
Somehow the upside down for us. And I will take this this example and and make it to Duell and we will write it down.
So we call this EF and then I'm going to have the duel and I'm going to call out the reverse of F now.
And I'll write that to the right. Come on.
I'll show you how we how we do it, how the way the way that I'm going to do it is a is a little bit strange but but but but it works.
And so that's why I do it that way. And there are several other ways.
But this is the one that the turn out to lead to all kinds of properties that in fact, the most of what I'm saying today is, is new.
I mean, isn't hasn't been published. And it was surprising to a standing when I told him at M.I.T. and so on and other people who work in this area.
And I don't have time to write a paper about it right now, so pay attention.
Others being videotaped, I guess, what now? So what we're gonna do is I'm going to write the I'm gonna represent the forest versus a binary tree.
And I'm and I'm putting siblings together, you know, you know, backwards from the normal way.
I'm saying that the the last link in the binary tree is going to point to to the sibling,
to the left and the right link in the binary tree is going to point to the right most child.
So I is going to have rightmost child. Jayjay doesn't have anything.
He has child B and B has A rightmost C, and then C has two children.
The rightmost is H and then is D and then D has E.
E has G and F.
Now that the normal way to represent a force inside a computer is is using the right link for your right child in the left link for your,
for your left most chop. Here I'm using the right link for your right most child and the left link for your left sibling.
I'm switching the whole thing around. You think that it wouldn't make any difference but in fact it makes a big difference.
I never realized it until I was doing one of the exercises for the revised Volume one earlier this year.
And the the the important thing about the the left sibling right child representation instead of the the right sibling left out of mentation,
is that if you read this binary three in prio in in symmetric order.
This is the left-to-right order of in order.
It corresponds to the pre order of the forest. So if I'm reading it,
reading in symmetric order means you take everything to the left of the room
first and and then you take the route and then you take everything to the right.
And the left of the route starts with A, then B and C, and then I have to through the D e f g h i j.
So so the symmetric order of this binary tree is the pre order of the forest.
And it doesn't work out so nice when you do the other way. Now, now I've got this in something that's symmetrical between left and right.
So I just flip it and I go j. A b c.
D. E c h. D. E gene f.
And, you know, I just just take a mirror image and now I convert this back and consider this a forest.
This is gonna be. This is gonna be the dual force. So f reversed is is gonna have two trees.
J. And I whose left child is A, B, C H has all these children and HSN has the E and G and G has F.
So that's the reverse of that. That's the dual of that for us.
Now what good is this like.
Or we could have this operation and the and the interesting thing is that if F is Kuis related to G,
then G, then G Duell is Kruijff related to F tool.
So that says that if that you that you can flip the diagram upside down, the dual one is big, bigger than the other is duelist ma.
And so that's that that's this notion of duality.
Now, basically, you can prove this by induction.
By looking at the covering relations that then you figure out what's the dual of this guy?
And what's the deal of this guy. And you can see that the in the case of the duels, they're going to go this way.
We're going to detach something from the duel and move it to the duel of that one.
I don't have time to go through to the proof, but that's the beauty.
The idea of the proof. Now, I told you about kuris laughs.
I'm going to talk to you next about the tomato that my wife was the first lattice of trees.
That was that was discovered. And this is the one that I actually was one of my previous Christmas tree lectures was about.
This took this to my lettuce.
It was a call that the associative law and we and we studied the we said that one one tree could be changed into another tree.
Bye bye bye. What computer science call a rotation operation on a tree.
And it gained its equivalent algebraically to applying the associative law in a
formula changing a B quantity quantity a B time C into eight times quantity B,
C and however, I'm not going to say that that was the way tomorrow defined his letters.
But it turns out that there's another way, in some ways maybe nicer to define to my letters which I'm going to which which which corresponds
very directly to to one of the one of the ways that that people have been for 30 years,
almost 40 years now, representing forests inside a computer.
In fact, that instead of calling them for us, they call them COBOL Data Division and the representation and the COBOL compiler writers 1916.
Just this found that the best way to represent COBOL structures was in terms of something that's very close to where I'm going to define it tomorrow.
Right. So here we have the second thing is the Temari letters. And we're going.
And I'm going to say that Jeff is tomorrow you're related to, gee, this is going to mean by definition that the number of descendants.
Of of X in F is less than or equal to the number of descendants of X in vaccine G for all X.
In other words, the first note preorder of F has the same has has fewer descendants than the first order preordering n g.
And so on. So, so on. So it's all based on knowing the number of descendants of every of every note in the form.
Now let's let me let me go to our example example, a forest here and let's figure out how many descendants everybody has here.
So A, b, c, d, e, f, g, h i, j.
So as I'm talking property senators, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So it has seven descendants. B has one, two, three, six.
C has one, two, three, four, five. D has three.
He has two. F Anji non h non i1 to zero.
So. So I have with this, I have this coordinate system.
Seven, six, five, three, two. That's it. That's another way to describe the structure of this forest.
It turns out from these numbers, I can reconstruct them. And let me show you how to do that.
So. So inside of inside of the other computer, trying to represent stuff of a forest or a hierarchical type of population.
And I put this these numbers here. Seven, let's put my PI.
Seven, six, five. These are called us the scope of the of the node.
It's the number of descendants it has. It's how how far the influence extends in preorder.
To the right. So I listed the names of the nodes in this preorder.
And now he has a scope of seven. So we go one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, and we leave.
These guys are all descendants of a. These guys are all descendants.
And B, C has these. D comes here.
He comes here. I should left myself more room. All right. Okay.
So this tells you where the where the family is.
And so so it's it's it's obvious and A has B as a child and then B as he is.
And C has D as a child. And D and E and E F G but E doesn't have H.
So, so it must go back to somebody who has the scope here that will see.
So that's the way it reconstructionist. I think so.
So these these coordinates are equivalent to this to the structure, the numerical way to represent the structure and the rules.
And not not every sequence of numbers is going to be a set of coordinates. In this way.
You seek to see which ones are going to be the ones that are that are OK.
Are the ones where these lines never cross. The corners are bad.
If you have if somebody here would say, you know, six and then and then it goes over, one, two, three, four, five, six.
And somebody here would say maybe three.
And that would stand out here because you can't have because this guy can have descendents that aren't also Utusan.
So that's it should not be necessary, sufficient condition at that,
that if you draw these these scope links like this, that they aren't going to cross over each other now.
So it's real easy to tell then tomorrow. Is it whether or not one force is related to another?
You just look at their at their at their scopes, at these coordinates, and you compare what, one at a time?
Each one has to be less than or equal to the corresponding one and the other in the other side.
That's the that's the idea of tomorrow. Now, now this theorem is to be the same as what we had before.
That duality still applies. So if indeed if and only if the dual of G is Tamai related to the dual of all of them?
Oh, that's obvious. Because what I've done here is I have changed left and right.
OK. This symmetric order is symmetrical between left and right. And so what's actually happening here?
If I. If I. Let me let me see.
Do I have to talk about covering Christmann? I guess maybe I need covering in order to.
Yeah. I got to explain covering in order to show you why this is why just here.
And it's obvious that. But let them let me give the coordinates of the duel anyway.
So. So the duel in the duel. I'm going to give the coordinates and preorder against.
I'm going to call a G IPD CBA. And so Jay has no descendants, I has one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, H four.
She has one. E F has nine.
E d nine. CBA none. So.
So the dual this coordinates are these coordinates. And actually I don't know any easier way to.
I don't know any easy way to describe this except by, by this binary tree representation.
Take the forest and. Well I know how to go from the scarp links to a binary tree.
And then I flip the binary tree over and then I can figure out the scope scopes again.
But this is a theory. But I prevent it ahead of time.
So, like, I got to talk about the covering tomorrow. When is it?
What are the what are the relations. Right. So let's let let me first show you a picture of my Latisse.
And one of the pictures is here.
It's kind of a mess, but I'll clean it up later.
The first main thing I want to show you in the picture is that I've got I've got these same six the same 14 Faust's written down here as before.
But I've also now added in blue these these numbers.
These are my coordinates. And to tell when something is is kamari less than another, it means that Kornet wise, it's less of a zero zero zero.
So it's going to be less than everything. Here's this. Two thousand is going to be less than twenty one hundred.
And in its end, that's the end. It's less than thirty one hundred two.
But that's not a covering relation.
So, so I've shown with in red lines again, only the covering relations of twenty one hundred thirty one hundred thirty three hundred thirty two.
Ten is the big guy here. He has three to send it CBS to see as one.
This is the one at the top. So by looking at any two of these trees by the court systems, you can immediately tell whether they're related.
But the red lines are the covering lines showing you which are something that's just bigger than this.
You know, there's nothing between two hundred and thirty two hundred. And that's that's obvious.
If you look at the if you if you look at this, this non crossing condition, because the two hundred has a has a score going out here.
So. So if you're gonna increase the one in front of it, you're going to have to give it a scope of three.
Well, now, I already talked a lot about it tomorrow Latisse.
So I'm not going to repeat what I did in that lecture. But I wanted to.
But but in the covering, I do want to show you what the covering relation is in it.
In my lesson. So if we look at the binary trees form of the of the forest instead of the instead of the four, the other form in a binary tree.
We have a situation like this. Here's a node. Here's a node.
It has two some trees. And this guy has another subtree, Cawley's Alpha, Beta and Gamma.
And the the number of descendants of this node is is called absolute value of theta.
That means the number of nodes in this industry data. So that's how many descendants this guy has.
Because to the right is it we're listening at the right.
All of the all the descendants of an end to the left.
The left sibling. The similarly here, the to my coordinate is the number of descendants of this node, which is the size of this tree.
Now, the the customary covering relation would take this into a.
There's also an environment. So so this is part of the binary tree.
It has some some attachment to a larger tree.
Perhaps you from the right or the left. But it does apply.
So what we do is we rotate it. And after a rotation in a binary tree, it's one of the very it's the most fundamental operation for.
For balancing a binary trees used in lots of different computer programs. Then we have alpha, beta and gamma.
The nodes are still the same in in symmetric order.
First come in all the notes of Alpha. Then comes this guy. Then all the most beta.
Then comes this guy, then harmless gamma. Same on this side. It's Alpha. This alpha.
This. But now notice what's happened.
This guy still has gamma. The number the size of gamma is the number is my corner here.
But the Tamai, according to this guy, is one plus the size of beta plus size of gamma.
Because now that's the size of the right sub through here. So you can see that this operation has increased.
That has increased. Exactly. One of the coordinate of the tomorrow coordinates.
And it's and it increases to the smallest possible value. If you took any any value smaller than one plus beta plus gamma to this guy, it is tough.
It wouldn't it wouldn't satisfy this non-critical, you know, it would violate this condition.
So the short run going to increase this this to my Kornet from absolute veto to anything else,
it has to be enough to to avoid crossing the link from this guy to his show.
So so basically, by studying this kind of idea, you realize that this is this this is exactly the smallest.
This is this tree is above this one in the Tamar reordering.
And there's nothing in between in the Temari ordering. And furthermore, all of the coverings are of this kind.
So so the covering relations are formed that way.
Well, now what's happening is that if I if I if I flip left and right.
To take to do all of the operation then then then we have different coordinates.
Because now we're counting the size of the left of trees that are the size of the right set in the corner.
So if I'm flipping left, right. So what must happen is that that the operation of the duel must be taking the dual coordinates.
And every time I do a positive rotation, I'm sort of doing a negative rotation on the dual.
So the conclusion is that if somebody if somebody is if you know,
every every covering relation and the tomorrow Latisse increases the positive coordinates.
And in a duel, it decreases it decreases it because it'll it'll go from you'll go from something like this to something like this.
If you flip left and right.
Therefore, uncovering relations, the duel of this is less than then the duel of this if this is less than this for the book.
So, so, so, so flipping left and right. This is going to be less than that because flipping left and right.
Also converts converts this side to this.
That's why I had the feeling that I know I mentioned a minute ago that the the that's the duality is reverse.
So. So again, this this diagram, if I tipped it on its side, the red lines would be in the same position.
Because what I've done is I flip the duel of this guy over here in a duel with this guy over here.
These people, I, I worked everything out so that the duel was within the consequently 180 degree rotation in position of the.
Oh, the elephant. So for now, there's another thing I wanted to show you about this picture, though,
and that is the next term, which which is why I know why I like this this way of representing the forest.
And that is that if it is related to G in a curious lattice, then yes, it's also related to G in the Temari letters.
So you lovely places aren't are independent of each other, but there's a strong connection between them, so.
So what does it mean to picture a picture wise?
It says that anybody who isn't any any relation in the in the in a curious lattice also corresponds to the same the same relation in like here.
This this tree has to be less than this one. Well, that's this tree is less than this one.
It isn't directly less than this one, but it's less than this, which is less than this one tomorrow.
So so that's the the theorem that relates one to the other.
It says that that being being kuris related is a stronger condition than being tomorrow related.
But they are exactly analogous. But this is a little course of a little causal relation.
And and this term is also obvious because if you look at at at at the covering in the curious lattice, what we've done.
If I can only find the picture of the covering and the clearest light. So we've done something that increases the coordinates.
So if we look at that, if we look at the tomorrow coordinates, how many descendants everybody has here.
This was the guy that has. This was the big guy.
This is a small guy. And and you see that the number of descendants of everybody here is is the same.
Except that except that all the people on on this right path here have have gotten more descendants than they had here.
So all of this all of the all of the Kumari coordinates of of some of these nodes are bigger than they were up here.
But inside the rest of the diagram to my Corden's haven't changed. So.
So by going from from here to here, I increase some tomorrow cause I don't decrease any to my audience.
And that's why it's less than the other one into my land.
Because to my definition is only is based on the cornets entirely.
So so now I've got this, this idea of Tamara Latticed, my promise you three lattices.
I'm going to the third one, which is Estanislao. Right before I do that, let me just mention why do we study these things?
I mean, you know, the the the things are turned out to be rather beautiful when you start looking at them on Facebook.
But so what? And I, I, I don't know.
Years ago, I wouldn't even have have raised that question because it was to me, you know,
it was so obvious that it's that it's interesting to discuss this stuff that I that I didn't mention any other justification.
But anyway, so some people now think the only purpose of computer scientists to make money for other people.
So so is how does this make money for anybody else? And so my answer to that is, well, historically,
it's always turn out that whenever there's a clean mathematical relation between fundamental objects that we work with everyday like trees for.
This turns out to give us more familiarity with those objects. And and we can we we study these things.
We look at them. All of a sudden we're more comfortable with trees and we see bigger, bigger pictures.
We take giant steps. When we when we start thinking about trees, we are able to envision many more things to do to do with them.
We think of other structures that are there, are built on top of these.
And it's because we because we've gotten some fluency, you know, in the old days.
Did you have a name of what a mathematical concept of a tree was?
And and neither do we have names for other things that we now use everyday, like vectors and fields and lattices.
So by studying these properties of these things, especially when they're when they're clean and natural,
it always has turned out that this has this has led to later developments in the next generation.
So it's isn't this is another lattice on on permutations.
It's turned out that it was first discovered by some scientists in 1960.
And I did a search for it. And there's been hundreds of papers on this written since then where people found all kinds of ways to use that light,
that lattice, which is now it's now called the brouhaha lattice.
But anyway, there's so many people finding important ideas of this class.
I related it to sorting networks and all kinds of things that weren't clear originally why they would be important.
But when there's something quite natural like this, it always seems the history always makes it important.
So. So that's why that's why I think this is cool stuff.
OK. Now, Stanley letters and here I wish I could instead of using an S, I'm just going to use.
I'm just going to use the ordinary subset notation because it looks a little bit like an S and I can I can I can use like,
you know, for the you know, for the the opposite relation.
I could also say G is related to F like this, you know.
And the meat can be written this way and the joint can be written this way.
So I have symbol for interesting. Let us just use ordinary sets in the meat custom caps.
So anyway, what does this mean.
And this is says simply that the depth of X in F is less than or equal to the depth of X in G for all X in the same way.
So so here we have have coordinates of a forest that are different.
To my quarters. It's my Corless. We listed how many descendants everybody had.
I don't have another color pen so I'm just going to write it.
So these are the tomorrow coordinates. The standard coordinates in this forest.
Are they the death of a or is a definite zero?
B is a depth one. See, the depth to this is a step three.
See what I'm doing. How far down did I go. Is is for f Anji are at five h.s.
One, two three I zero. G is one. Okay.
And in the do I can I can show its depth two.
So J with zero I zero H. One key is to just write them down.
Three, two, two one one one.
OK now. So to compare two things according to Stanley ordering.
We just compare component wise to see whether their coordinates are are related.
The first one is always zero. The next one would have to be less than or equal.
And. There's there's a very simple way to get from the T corners to the S corners or pull back again.
Can anyone see the. First of all, I give you a clue to some of the tea corners equals the sum of the S coordinates.
That's called the path length of the forest, because the the the sum of the SS is the the sum of the distances to the root.
And that's that's what we use in so many applications called the path length that corresponds
in a computer program that corresponds a number of times with the processing things.
So I think this is important.
Many applications, but also it's also the number of the sentence of a plus the number in sense B, because a number of things have come through.
A is the number of descendants of a number of things that come through B as the. OK.
So you see how to get from the one to the other.
And the answer is that we take the tomorrow coordinates seven, six, five, three to an hour for the seven.
I will convert that to zero one one one one one one one.
I put seven one stop for the six, I put down six one for the file.
I put down five ones for the three. I put down three ones to I put down two once.
And for this I j. I put in another one, I add these altogether and I get to zero.
One, two. Three, four, five. Three zero one.
Those are the family court. OK.
So in other words, just having it having 70 centers means that you're going to increase the level of all these next seven guys by one.
So you can easily get from one set of quarters to the other. That means that the next theorem is obvious.
If F is to marry related to G, then F is a standard related to G.
So. So because you see, if F is tomorrow related to G, that means that F coordinates are component life less than or equal to G score.
So if we. So then they're gonna be lower bounds for the, for the, for the cornice that you get from start from, for Stanley.
Everything I add, you know, if I change the seven to eight,
I would I would think I would be a one here that would increase the standard Kornet by one.
Why change any of these numbers? Make them bigger. Why increase the.
So that's. So that's the really the relation that is similar to what we what we should.
You see the curious relation implied QMI relation not to my relation and plays of Tanyalee.
So. So now that means that we should be able to take this.
Take a look at the Stanley. Here's here's the stat.
Here's a Stanly word. And people who study lattices will recognize immediately that this lattices is is nice, as it is called,
a distributed lattice distributive lattices where these operations meet and join not only satisfy the purity of associative absorption and so on laws,
but they also satisfy the spirit of law. X meet Y joint zie is equal to X, meet Y joined with Sleezy and the other distribution as well.
And the Gladys's. When you look at them, tend to look like cubes and and and grids and things like that.
Lisa Small, a small example. And they have. They have a definite structure made out of little cells and and other properties this size.
But anyway, this is this. So this lattice meeting joins in the static standard that it's also satisfy the the distributed line.
And the reason is simple, because the family coordinates. We have to see what does it mean?
What are the legal sequences of Stanly coordinates? What what sequences of integers are going to describe the standard cordons of a forest?
And the reason is that that sequence?
S one as to ascend. Is it is it a Stanley Courteney's sequence given only if one is zero.
And s I first one is less than or equal. Yes, I was.
When you eat as you go from left to right, you start with zero. And then then each one is most one higher than the previous.
I guess we can have more about. So. So.
So after a zero I can go to zero or one. After one I can go as much up to two.
After the five I could've gone to six. I could pick the five here I could go as high as six.
But. But that's. If and only if so. So now if you have if t one through ten is also a family sequence of coordinates then then
s one a minimum of S one and T one through the minimum of S one two T N and the maximum.
If I use these operations for men, Max, are also going to be are also going to be standing because it,
because the maximum of ESSI plus one and t'ai plus one is going to be less than or equal to max of this plus one.
So and similarly with men. So. So this operation on, on the coordinates makes it easy to to take the easy.
You just you just take Min and Max on the coordinates and you get the Stanley Stanley upper bound and lower bound.
And that's why this this is a distributed less if I take the Samari lattice.
That's what you just mentioned.
And the next minute Max are distributed and Max the final that is it on the integers minute Max defined the serious lattice that looks like this.
I mean the latest diagram is. Yes. Like this.
Which is it? Because they just figured it was indeed that that it's somehow the simplest.
Right. I have another theory in that that I could I could I could build all the forests
into into a lattice that has the structure just by lexical graphic order,
say, on the Spanish border. And so then one thing led to another, which is something less standing wise would also be less than this,
is that this land would have 14 levels or concrete.
Here I've taken the here I've taken the standard Courtice. I converted into my accordion's equivalent to my core.
And it's put put the things in the same place and drawn again the covering relations in the Tamar lattice.
Well, you go to covering relations in this valuated and this is this is an illustration of my fear and that says that if F is is is a.
Related to gee by tomorrow.
Meaning that if I if I take any any one of these red lines here, then that's going to correspond to some path in the standard.
This one is less than note and understanding. I have a path from here to there.
So so here again, this shows that the tomorrow letter somehow is if it gives more, gives you more information, understanding.
But it's astounding. This is a is a is nice because it's mysterious.
It has has has. Now I've noticed. This was all a strange concept for me to have a letter, have several lattices on the same point.
I've seen studies where people take a lesson and they identify causes of his points and then they get Congress to get other kind of.
But I've not. But I haven't. I'm not sure. I don't even know what the name for the concept is.
It's not this isn't a subset of this letters. I think I can say it's embedded in the letters it has.
But I know I'm not sure what the right. It's that it's happening in these Gladys's.
So. So I'm going to have to get more familiar with the concept.
One of the one of the one of the choral areas of this is is for example, that is that the the meat in the kamari,
this would have to be contained in the meat in the Stanley lettuce because you see if
meat G in the standing lettuce is the greatest lower bound in the Stanley lettuce.
And so but. But it's great for a bone of FFG.
But F or me. G. Tomorrow lettuce is the lower bound on air and it's a lower bun on G.
And so it has to be less than the greatest amount. So for looking at in the Stanley lettuce, we're gonna have this relation.
Yeah. Short cuts. What looks like the short cuts.
The other one one might say short cuts. Yeah, that's right.
Yeah. It says that there's whenever I have a covering here coming here, then I have a chain here.
So, so, so, so yeah.
There's a short cut glass. And similarly if I, if I went to the kuris lattice and went back to that there would be short cuts
there because Chris Lettuce had only three steps from the bottom to the top.
That, by the way, the curious lettuce, the levels in the crucifies with a number of leaves, if you remember.
And. And leaves are easily seen in the meat because the leaf means means no dissent.
And so that's a number of zeros. And so in the.
So in the you know, if you look at here, you can see how many leaves. So you look how many zeros there are.
And you can see. So. So I've got some cases with two zeros.
Operator Hi. Here. But but these would still be in the second D would you say this is one zero anyway.
The number of zeros anyway tells you the level in the cruiser in the Crewther.
But there's, there's still more information as to as to the courier letters as to who's who's containing who.
Now there's still this picture isn't very intuitive here.
I was saying before, you know, when you draw a picture of a lattice, you want to have some diagram that explains that explains what it is.
Here are the 14 for us on four points. And and I and I want to find a way to draw them.
What time is it, by the way? I am. I don't have twenty, twenty past five.
Okay. So I got I got to start speeding up anyway. I've got to get to.
Interesting problem. I want to tell you about it.
So here's here, for example is a paper that came out a few years ago.
Shows that lattice again. It's it's not really. It's a little bit cleaner than be my drawing.
You know, what does. But there it is.
Heard it described it not in terms of forest, but in terms of of an equivalent concepts of dividing a polygon into triangles and those.
Again, that's what was the primary level. Here's another picture by another by Mycoskie getting has a picture tomorrow.
My letters. But, you know, it doesn't it doesn't look appealing now.
So I'm trying to figure out what this was.
A year ago, I gave a talk at Berkeley at the craft drawing conference, and I wasn't talking about the tomorrow lightest,
but just the connectivity, the the things that you can get from when you take two trees.
What, what? What? Two trees. Jason, if you can get from one to another by a rotation.
And so every all of these covering relations in my life correspond to rotations. We ignore the.
The top down part part of it, but just look at the connectivity between these things and say, how could I draw that in a nicer way?
And I'm thinking about this here.
I want to show this is for the first time I'm showing publicly the page from the new edition of Volume three of the art of computer programing,
which I hope some of the publishers next month. I'm still working on it.
But but anyway, here's a pic. Here's a picture. It's also in the previous edition, not quite as beautiful.
And this shows a different lattice. This is the latest on permutations where it's it's the inversion lattice of permutations that
one permutation is less than another if it's inversions are some sort of inversion of the other.
And here I notice that we can also see this as if it was as if it was in three dimensions.
And and it's it's called a truncated octahedron. And you get it from from taking an octahedron and lop off some of the vertices.
And you get this this interesting shape has hexagon faces and square.
Well, I wanted to do this. This people call us all the Permuted Hedeman because it's a poly hedren that that's based on fermentation.
And the Temari lattice has been called the Associate Hedren because it's a.
It turns out that people have found a way to find a polygon that whose whose faces and
vertices and edges correspond to the structure of our application of the social well.
So in my talk to the at Berkeley to the graph drawing thing,
I took the Kamari lattice and I say I tried to draw the best way I could use a price and principle that I was talking about there.
And this was my best shot at it afterwards and started to look a little bit like,
you know, like something that that you can have in in and out, you know.
Oh, for goodness sake, I left. I left it upstairs. I had a model that I wanted to show you.
Oh, terrible. Well, now, yesterday, I decided let's look at this thing.
This has this has six faces that are pentagons. One, two, three.
And then underneath the three, the three things on the back are Pentagons.
And then it has three that are squares and, you know, or at least a quadrilateral for a side.
So, so. So I said, well, let me try to build one of these.
So I. So I took Oarsome. So there's a knife and I cut six hexagons Pentagons.
I mean and I and I made him regular Pentagons and I and I and I it and paste them around.
And I got something that I tried to draw today and this was the best I could do.
But it looks sort of like what I got it was actually a very appealing a little little thing.
And I I'm sorry I left it on one of the big one of the highest.
And I talked to to you on it on camera here. But anyway, this is almost gives you the idea now.
So what I think here is I took five, 10, six Pentagons and I grabbed them together in this pattern and then identify the vertices with the with
their tomorrow coordinates here and connect to things that are that are connected by a rotation.
Now, I'm not sure this is really a this this is really a legitimate solid.
I haven't worked out that it might be that. I mean, I'm sure that these Pentagons hooked together this way,
but I'm not sure that these that these places where you get four points here, I'm not sure that those are all in the same plane.
Maybe that was why I was I was having trouble trying to sketch it because I
built it out of out of paper and and my sisters and I didn't I didn't take much,
much care. I just sort of trace that would look like a regular, you know, so I could vegetal that.
Okay. But even even so, something very close to this is actually, you know, maybe the Pentagon's aren't gonna be regular.
But but but you've got to you've got to shake like this in the following way.
You take two tetrahedron. And you pastern and you grow them together.
So so that now way to the faces are just on top of each other.
So now what you have left is is a hex heat and it has three from one point one tetrahedron, the three from the other.
And it's been good together.
So it has it has three vertices where they were glued together and two other vertices that used to be the top of each curve of each slope tetrahedron.
So you've got this thing with five vertices and six faces now.
Now you take the three vertices in the middle and you cut in, cut each of them off.
That that converts that vertex into four vertices because that's how much is surrounding it.
And so you've added three plus three plus three vertices and you've gone from fiber's to 14 vertices, which is the which is this thing.
So here, if you imagine these four things where we shrunk to a point and these forward shrunk two points,
you'd get this this Hex Hedren, this dispute, this thing has two tetrahedron put together.
And and so so now I what I what I'm doing is say take your your Hexa Hedren and try to chop it off at.
The thing that's most esthetically pleasing, go make these squares too small.
They'll make them too big, but make them so that it looks nice and maybe it'll be.
So I couldn't find any books this this figure made out of Pentagons and squares.
And so it probably doesn't exist. But it's not just this is not okay.
But they look so I don't know any any revenues. But here's my here's my my my question.
And that is, first of all, to find the most,
I would like to know people using nice three dimensional drawing tools and so on to find need the best visualization of a real truncated Hexa Hedren.
And you find that the view that makes it that makes it best so that, you know, you have room to draw in the labels,
these coordinates and things like this, you know, so it's like you can write it for a nice texture.
And and and furthermore, you have to you have to position it, if possible, so that it respects the lattice ordering.
Here. I didn't respect the last thought on this. Three, two, one zero is the top element here.
So so I have to tip this guy in such a way that the that the that gravity also corresponds to making it into my core and it's bigger.
Is that possible? I believe that as an open, interesting, open problem.
Here's my best my best diagram of my life right now.
And it doesn't know if this satisfies the gravity condition.
And it looks a little bit intuitive, but it's but it but I would much prefer something that looks like the one we have four permutations.
If somebody can think of one. So. Huh. So I can't show you the other beautiful things I want to show.
For example, the the number of paths in the curious lattice.
The number of ways to go through from the bottom to the top of the surest lattice on and things turns out to be exactly end to the end minus two.
And it is a beautiful,
beautiful one to one correspondence between that and several other things like parking functions that I talked about in my previous thought.
But one thing I got to mention just at the end is that an hour before I get I get this lecture,
I learned about yet another lattice of four on forest that has just been discovered.
And I call it Andrew's letters. And it's some and.
And it's he actually doesn't describe in terms of a lattice at all.
But Groucho standing by by studying the details is thinking about a while I was
able to to realize that he's really getting a distributed lattice out of this.
And here's a picture of it on four on four elements. And it's, again, a way to describe things by terms of coordinates.
And you compare things coordinate by coordinate. So here's a.
And so I did this just 50 minutes before today.
So I haven't observed with Andrew's lattices yet. But it's that if somebody wants to look at it, I'll be glad to talk.
Talk to you about it, because I would be I wouldn't be surprised if there wasn't a way to to to map the Stanley
lattice so that anything that's standard related is also gonna be Andrew Andrew's related.
And we get yet another call because this this seems to be, you know,
yet another natural way to define relations on force that that turns out to be distributive and and has elegant properties.
So so this indicates that there's still looks like there's plenty of stuff to be done.
I had even a few more open problems. So I guess maybe next Christmas or the Christmas after that or one of the ones in the future,
I can again return to the topic of Lass's on treasons and tell people about
still more things that happen to be true about the beloved objects of trees.
And for us. Thanks a lot. Question.
Is there a concept you're referring to?